[Music]
good morning it's my pleasure to
introduce the mit150 symposium on
leaders in science and engineering
the women of MIT the core of MIT is
hundred fiftieth anniversary
celebrations is what comprises the core
of MIT thinkers students researchers and
professors talking about great ideas
contemplating the world and perhaps even
making a little progress on some of its
problems some of the other foot in
symposia this this term focus on
economics and finance which occurred in
late January conquering cancer through
science and engineering which was last
week computation and the transformation
of our world which will be in mid-april
the future of exploration in earth air
ocean and space which will be in late
April and finally new approaches to the
problem and tell of intelligence in
early May of course these topics in no
way cover the full range of the research
that goes on at MIT but they are a very
rich sampling of cutting-edge work that
epitomizes the best of MIT I also want
to particularly draw your attention to
the next century convocation which is on
April 10th celebrating the actual day of
the signing of the Charter I encourage
you all to register online and attend
it's free and the whole campus Plus
alumni are involved are invited it's
sure to be a stupendous
once-in-a-lifetime event a rare
opportunity for an entire community to
gather to honor scholarship service and
all the contributions of all the people
who comprise MIT this historic day will
renew our sense of belonging to a great
institution of accomplishment and
purpose as chair of the mit150 steering
committee and as an engineer and
historian of Technology I've become
something of a student of mi t--'s
history so I want to say a few words
about how today's symposium relates to
that larger history in 1853 William
Barton Rogers came north from Virginia
to
sooo his dream of a new kind of
technical education that would mix the
world of science and the useful arts
theory and practice what we have come to
know as men's at Manas mind and hand
Rogers vision was actually inclusive
professors lectures should be useful to
everyone he wrote which might draw all
the lovers of knowledge of both sexes to
the halls of the Institute as Charles
Eliot wrote in 1869 when he was an MIT
professor the graduates of this new
Institute with this new education would
require courage so much with their
preparation differ from those of other
leaders in their society with whom they
would rub shoulders no one would require
that card so much as the women of MIT
indeed just as Elliot was writing those
words a young woman Ellen swallow was
graduating from Vassar College as she
contemplated a career in the science
that she loved she wrote my life is to
be one of active fighting this spirit
suited her well to MIT of course which
forward-thinking but still insecure in
its early years and very much a product
of its time admitted her with hesitation
and off-the-books as an experiment
she became mi t--'s first alum in 18
first female first alumna in 1873 a nerd
in the finest MIT tradition her husband
proposed to her in an MIT laboratory and
they spent their honeymoon visiting
mines and collecting ore samples with
students in tow she became also in the
finest MIT tradition swallow Richards
went on to have an accomplished career
in teaching and science as the founder
of Home Economics her scientific
nutrition helped introduce ideas like
calories protein and carbohydrates into
the American home where they remain
today she also made major contributions
to food science mineralogy and
industrial chemistry among her many
other accomplishments she conducted a
comprehensive survey of water quality in
Massachusetts that led to the first
water quality standards in
United States swallow Richards also had
great accomplishments in teaching she
opened a woman's laboratory at MIT and
taught hundreds of women who would not
otherwise have had any access to
laboratory based education mi t--'s
unique trademark she even conducted
correspondence courses to teach women
science at home and sent them
microscopes in the mail and encouraging
them to explore their surroundings MIT
formally began accepting special
students quote without distinction of
sex in 1876 women were accepted as
regular students in 1882 the origins of
amitié the association of MIT alumna
date to 1899
as the MIT Women's Association of which
Richard was Richards was the first
president by 1916 when MIT moved across
the river from Boston to Cambridge more
than 600 women in total had attended the
Institute but the enrollment had
actually declined by then - less than 1%
of the student body and indeed this is a
theme you see running throughout the
first hundred years or so of the
Mighty's women which is outstanding
individuals but very small numbers to be
sure many of these few women were stars
with impact far beyond the walls of MIT
for example catherine dexter mccormick
class of 1904 who was a leader in the
women's suffrage movement supported
research and development for the birth
control pill and later in life endowed
McCormick Hall it was not until the 20s
and the 30s that most MIT apartments
awarded their first graduate degrees to
women the first women to receive a PhD
was in 1922 which you'll be hearing a
little bit more about later
Margaret Hutchinson Rousseau class of 37
received the first doctorate in chemical
engineering awarded to a woman in the
United States between 1940 and 1950 more
than 180 degrees were awarded to women
including 23 PhDs
graduates from this period included Mary
Francis waggly class of 47 in chemistry
the first woman on the MIT corporation
the first woman to head the Alumni
Association and MIT life member of the
corporation America
and also of course Emily Way class of 45
the second woman president of the Alumni
Association and also a corporation life
member America again though despite the
accomplished individuals after World War
two the numbers actually went down as
men returned from war and took up the
slots by 1964 the percentage of women
awarded degrees at MIT remained still at
only a few percent pretty much where it
had been in 1916 it would rise to 13
percent by 1979 and to 45 percent of
undergraduates today again among those
small numbers of course we find
remarkable women like today's panelists
the Honorable Shirley Ann Jackson she
would graduate in the class of 1968 and
in 1973 become the first
african-american woman to earn a
doctorate in physics when she received
her PhD from MIT the troubling small
numbers were not lost on the students in
1964 the Association of Women students
sponsored a national symposium titled
American women in science and
engineering that association and the
symposium were headed by this Venn
student Margaret MacVicar of course
Margaret MacVicar would go on to found
the Europe program as a 26 year old
junior faculty member become mi t--'s
first Dean of undergraduate education
and is today memorialized in mi t--'s
highest award for undergraduate teaching
the magnifica fellowships yeah we can
see that 1964 meeting that she and her
colleagues organized as something of a
predecessor to today's gathering yet
again despite stars like Margaret
MacVicar the number of women on the
faculty remained remarkably few the
first woman professor was nearly at MIT
centennial Elspeth Rostow appointed in
economics and social science in 1952 and
the first female professor in science
was Emily wick appointed in 1959 it's
telling that the first female faculty
member in engineering
now Institute professor sheila widnall
appointed in 1964 is still today a very
active member of our faculty the more
recent history of the last 50 years and
the events leading up to the nineteen
nine report and the one released last
week are the
subject of today's symposium and I won't
say too much about them in fact the
people on the panels are really the
people who made that history and I'm
sure that at the Bicentennial they will
be hailed as the pioneers as MIT
celebrates its 200th anniversary
my thanks to professors Cynthia Barnard
at birgenair penny Chisholm Barbara
Liskov hazel sieve Ian Waitz and
Katherine Wertheim for their willingness
to step up and organize this historic
gathering particularly their
coordination with the new research
results released in last week's report
nothing could be more exciting for an
MIT 150 symposia than to say something
new about this critical topic an
indication of the importance of this
topic for MIT and for science and
engineering in general is that of this
organizing committee we find to
associate Dean's and associate provost
and Institute professor to department
heads one of whom is now Dean I'd also
like to thank and acknowledge the mit150
staff led by Gail Gallagher and Ted
Johnson for the stupendous
organizational skills in pulling this
and so many events I think we have more
than 100 at this point all together it's
a pleasure for me and a privilege to
work with them according to the report
last released last week the changes that
have had the greatest impact in the past
10 years include increasing numbers of
women faculty increasing women faculty
and in the academic administration
including the president of MIT I will
now introduce Susan Hockfield the
president of MIT who not only represents
those positive changes but also has both
presided over and enacted many of them
herself
she's also provided the leadership and
the driving force between the MIT
hundred 50th celebrations for which I'm
deeply grateful
[Applause]
good morning everyone thank you David
David is very generous in his things but
we really have to thank him because he
has given the Institute truly a
tremendous gift in his leadership of the
entire and I would say entirely
wonderful mit150 celebrations you heard
again this morning what happens when mi
t--'s history is sifted and showcased by
a distinguished historian of Technology
it is just hugely illuminating and David
thank you for all your service including
today's window on the role of women in
shaping the early history of MIT I also
want to join David in thanking all those
who helped bring this symposium to life
the organizers the panelists the
moderators and especially our
distinguished speakers who have come
from great very great distances to be
with us today I'm really delighted to
have you join us now I sometimes say
that mi t--'s job is inventing the
future and today's symposium illustrates
this idea in a number of compelling ways
to start with the symposium stands as a
stunning demonstration of science and
engineering that go on at MIT
the researchers speaking over the next
two days represent the leading edge of
inquiry from computing to chemistry from
pure physics to Parkinson's disease and
over the course of the symposium you
will hear from three winners of the
National Medal of Science the nation's
highest distinction in science one
winner of the touring award basically
the Nobel Prize of computer science two
winners of a MacArthur Genius award two
Howard Hughes Medical Institute
investigators seven members of the
National Academy of Sciences four
members of the National Academy of
Engineering and pioneers who have mapped
the surface of Mars invented a battery
self-assembled by viruses Co discovered
the important role of tiny ocean
plankton
in the global nitrogen cycle and
discovered exoplanet atmospheres that
may be compatible with carbon-based life
by adding to the stock of new knowledge
in their respective fields these women
and everyone I just mentioned is a woman
are without question inventing the
future yet beyond their extraordinary
research they invent the future in other
ways too
they're directly engaged in educating
the next generation of pioneers in their
fields and at the same time they serve
as inspirational role models for young
women and men who seek rewarding lives
of discovery and innovation to borrow a
phrase from an illustrious MIT alumna an
extraordinary role model herself and I
quote education is changed by educating
successive generations you embed change
in a living Society inventing the future
indeed and it's our great honor that the
author of those words is with us today
Rensselaer's president Shirley Ann
Jackson and of course this symposium
celebrates and builds on yet another way
MIT is helping to invent event the
future through the Institute's
remarkable progress in making our campus
a richly supportive environment for
women faculty about 12 years ago MIT
released a report detailing measurable
inequities between women on this on the
faculty in the School of Science and
their male colleagues in lab and office
space in compensation and in
opportunities for advancement both the
report and the decision to release it
were signature MIT confident unflinching
and courageous confident because of the
data unflinching because of what the
data revealed and courageously committed
to solving the problem not just for MIT
but for the wider world in the year
since faculty and staff across the
Institute have used the report's
findings to improve our practice
is in everything from recruitment to
childcare and just last week the new
report on the status of women faculty in
the schools of science and engineering
at MIT made clear that our persistent
efforts have made a transformative
difference
the new report delivers the encouraging
message that progress is possible even
on such a deeply rooted social issue and
that progress is possible in the space
of years not lifetimes it also outlines
a set of issues that still remand our
attention including improved mentoring
and better distribution of Institute
responsibilities all this brings me to
this morning's symposium simply
overwhelming with gratitude to many
first I want to express our profound
thanks to the MIT women faculty who led
the groundbreaking charge for equity
spearheaded by Professor Nancy Hopkins
and those who took it upon themselves to
conduct the new study as well for any of
you who really like to see history you
can view Nancy's tape measure among the
150 objects collected at the MIT museums
exhibition celebrating our
sesquicentennial second hour things go
to the women and men who insisted on the
changes called for in the original
report and to those who have sustained
momentum for change since then in
particular I want to thank our guests
former dean of science Bob Birgeneau and
former MIT president Chuck vest for
facing the very difficult message of the
original report and for acting on those
findings we also owe a huge bouquet of
thanks to Provost Rafael rife for his
determined and relentless efforts over
the last almost six years to advance the
care the cause of equity and inclusion
his efforts take forms large and small
from insisting on broadened faculty
searches and appointing the Institute's
first associate provost for faculty
equity the listening very close
- here even the whispers of discomfort
and rapidly acting on them Raphael's
unswerving vigilance has kept these
issues front and center and is
responsible in large part for MIT
success in retaining and hiring so many
outstanding women faculty together in
the classic MIT spirit of can-do problem
solving these institute leaders have
produced results that are both
practically useful and personally
exhilarating for women in science and
engineering at MIT and around the world
I want to offer one last personal thank
you as a neuroscientist I am like many
of you a woman in science I lead an
institution that includes hundreds of
women scientists and engineers of every
age I also have a daughter who like many
of her friends is a young woman
preparing for a life in science I want
to thank all of those who have worked so
hard to make our institutions places
where no one questions a woman's right
to choose this path nor their right to
fair treatment every step of the way
above all thank you for inspiring them
and the women around the world with the
power and possibility shown by your work
in engineering and science it is truly a
gift to the world David mentioned Ellen
swallow Richards the first great pioneer
for women at MIT her example as a superb
researcher a brilliant student a
brilliant teacher and a tireless
advocate for women rings out in the
lives of the remarkable leaders we'll
hear from today Ellen swallow Richards
used to sign her letters with two words
keep thinking I'm confident that if we
keep thinking together MIT will continue
to earn its reputation for inventing the
future a brighter more fascinating more
equitable future for all thank you very
much
being with us today
and now I have the pleasure of
introducing to you someone who by
example demonstrates how an individual
can help advance equity and inclusion
professor ed Bertschinger head of the
department of physics his mentorship
includes a blog on mi t--'s diversity
website and his chairmanship of this
symposium through both his articulated
the importance of diversity and
inclusion in science and engineering a
member of the MIT Caverly Institute for
Astrophysics and space research he leads
a research program studying dark energy
and dark matter our Department of
Physics is among the world's top-ranked
physics departments for both research
and teaching professor birching R
believes that to amplify the
department's impressive reputation it
must actively reach out to
underrepresented minorities and women
ladies and gentlemen professor ed
Bertschinger
[Applause]
thank you very much president Hockfield
and David Mindell for your moving
remarks that helped put in context this
historic occasion I want to add my
thanks as well to the Institute staff
who helped put together these symposia
Ted Johnson the director of Institute
events Conference Services Manager Kathy
Levine Alison Newman and especially
physics events coordinator Nina Wu whose
hard work all of them made this
symposium come together I also want to
add my thanks to my fellow organizing
committee members
Cindy Barnhart penny Chisholm and Ian
Waitz from engineering Hazel sieve and
catch and Wareheim from the School of
Science and Barbara Liskov Institute
professor their advice and input and
encouragement in putting together this
symposium and in combining it with the
report that was mentioned were critical
in bringing together this event and I am
looking forward to celebrating with them
I want to thank Dean mark Kastner and
Dean Ian Waitz and his predecessor subra
Suresh for their financial support and
encouragement of this symposium a couple
of program notes there are 30 minute
breaks in the morning and in the
afternoon each day I would ask attendees
to return promptly from them so that we
can keep on schedule as best we can and
today at lunch lunch will be served for
with boxes available for those who
pre-registered and obtain the tickets on
the second floor of the Student Center
where we will celebrate with the family
of dr. Elizabeth Gatewood mi t--'s first
female PhD awarded in chemistry in 1922
over a year ago the organizing committee
set about preparing a symposium to
celebrate the success of women in
science and engineering at MIT with the
understanding that mi t--'s leadership
in recognizing and confronting its
problems of gender bias and
discrimination was a landmark while the
story of mi t--'s response was historic
another measure of MIT success is
the accomplishments of a growing number
of women faculty members this symposium
presents an outstanding set of
accessible talks by leaders in science
and engineering we were fortunate to
have these stars and many others on our
faculty and I'm personally delighted
that every MIT speaker who was invited
accepted the invitation and is here to
speak at the symposium in addition to
the science talks we will hear from very
distinguished speakers about the impact
of mi t--'s leadership across the nation
as well as our need to continue
improvements towards full equity many of
the ideas that will be discussed have
been raised by our own women faculty in
a report commissioned specifically for
this symposium which you have picked up
along with the program that report is a
follow up to the 1999 and 2002 reports
on women faculty in science and
engineering I thank all of the women who
contributed to the new report and
especially hazel sieve and Lorna Gibson
who chaired the science and engineering
sections
it gives me great pleasure to introduce
our keynote speaker professor Nancy
Hopkins she is the Amgen professor of
biology and a celebrated micro biologist
professor Hopkins studies early
development longevity and predisposition
to cancer in zebrafish she has made this
little fish a model for studies of those
important elements of her own human
physiology the importance of this work
has led to her election to the National
Academy of Sciences the Institute of
Medicine and the American Academy of
Arts and Sciences in addition to her
scientific contributions professor
Hopkins is well known for her work
promoting gender equity in academia she
chaired the committee that wrote the
1999 report on the status of women in
the school of science over the past year
I've had the special pleasure to get to
know professor Hopkins as a colleague a
friend and mentor Nancy Hopkins will now
give our keynote address on the status
of women in science and engineering at
MIT please join me in welcoming her
okay well I don't have to talk fast cuz
I think I'm already behind him my
schedule so I hope I have time to do all
this can I get the first slide up see
here we go
okay well thank you very much ed and
Susan and David and thank you to the
organizers for the opportunity to
reflect on the changing status of women
in science and engineering at MIT so if
you've happened to read a newspaper or
magazine in the last 30 years you've
undoubtedly read about the
under-representation of women in science
and engineering in the United States
particularly at the high end of these
professions and know yet doubt you have
heard of the infamous leaky pipe line
which refers to the fact that talented
women in science and engineering have
traditionally left these fields at a
higher rate than men at every stage of
career so by the time you get to the top
as we heard the percent of women is
still quite small enormous amounts of
time energy money have been spent
analyzing this problem and today we
really know quite a lot about it perhaps
not surprisingly MIT has made several
very significant contributions to
understanding the leaky pipe line
what causes it and how to fix it it
turns out that understanding this
problem requires that you do two things
analyze the numbers of women in science
and engineering as a function of time
and what changed those numbers and
examine the experiences of the women who
first entered these fields as
undergraduates moved on to graduate
school join university faculties in
Cambridge became professors when you do
these two things the mystery actually
begins to evaporate and if quite
fascinating story emerges today I'm
going to take you through that story
using primarily MIT data and experiences
but what I have to say really applies to
all comfortable research universities
and much of what I have to say about the
leaky pipeline of women in science and
engineering pertains to the advancement
of women to the top of other previously
male-dominated occupations it might
surprise you to know that the percent of
women on the science faculty of MIT
today is greater than the percent of
women in the United States Senate
shocking I'll begin with numbers that
display the leaky pipeline I'll use
again data from MIT throughout this
whole talk because if there's one thing
that MIT excels at as you know it's
collecting data and all in American data
I'm going to show is thanks to Lydia
Stover and her wonderful colleagues in
the Office of Institutional research at
MIT so I thank them for all the work
that they have contributed to our
efforts over many years this slide shows
the percent of MIT undergraduates
graduate students and faculty
undergraduates at the top science and
engineering faculty today about 45% of
undergraduates majoring in science and
engineering at MIT are women 29% of
graduate students and 17% of the science
and engineering faculty combined so
that's the drop-off that I mentioned
with the leaky pipeline 45 29 17 this
picture can be disturbed divided into
two distinct segments as David referred
to earlier for the century ending in the
mid 1960s and late and mid-1960s to
early 70s fewer than 5% of MIT
undergraduates and PhD students were
women except during the two world wars
when men went away and there were no
women faculty in science and engineering
in this period then suddenly the student
curves began to Mars dramatically in the
late 60s early 70s and the faculty
curves began to rise above zero and then
they increase in the early 70s why is
this the turning point was the passage
of the 1964 Civil Rights Act and
subsequent affirmative action laws and
the women's movement which altered
people's thinking dramatically about the
role of women in society but why are
there no women on the science and
engineering faculty for the first
hundred years after all a few women got
PhDs as early as the 1920s as we heard I
don't know the answer for MIT
specifically because I wasn't here but
the following anecdote his applies
probably to most universities in the
United States when I was a graduate
student in 1960s I worked summers at the
Cold Spring Harbor lab
I met a remarkable woman scientist named
Barbara McClintock I was in my early 20s
Barbara in her late 60s I thought she
was ancient I think in this picture
she's actually in her 80s one day
Barbara showed me a letter that had been
written a number of years earlier
probably in the 1940s to a biology
department chair by a well-known
geneticist the chair was soliciting
suggestions for candidates to fill a
faculty opening in his department the
geneticists had offered several
candidates names and then added of
course the number one person in the
world in this field his problem
McLintock it's too bad you can't hire
her because she's a woman Barbara told
me she could not get a faculty job in
any university science department only
in home economics departments so women
simply could not get faculty jobs and
science departments before the mid-1960s
fortunately Barbara managed to get a job
as a research scientist at Cold Spring
Harbor with support from the Carnegie
Foundation and by the way at the age of
81 she won the Nobel Prize in medicine
now I mentioned this story because we
think of science as a meritocracy and to
a very large degree it is but barbara
mcclintock story shows that societal
beliefs can overpower merit you could be
the best in the world and still not be
hired so as we see in this slide in 1964
it became illegal to deny women access
to jobs based on gender in addition the
number of women science and engineering
majors began to climb nationally as did
the number of graduate students women
began to be hired onto science and
engineering faculties so people assumed
after that it was just a matter of time
until women would quickly comprise half
the science and engineering faculty but
that was not what happened as the next
slide shows in greater detail for the
science faculty of MIT so the previous
slide showed the percent of women
faculty in science and engineering
combined and this slide shows the actual
number of women faculty just in the six
departments at MIT as a function six
science departments of MIT as a function
of time so in 1960 there actually
weren't any women in the current six
departments of science that we have
today they began to be hired in the mid
1960s and by 1970 the number
reach - there were 264 men then after
1971 the number shoots up by a factor of
10 why is that 1971 saw the
implementation of the affirmative action
regulations under the 1964 Civil Rights
Act the Schulz regs named after then US
Secretary of Labor George Shultz the
Schulz regs required universities to
submit written plans to hire women and
to do so or risk losing their federal
funding women were hired because the
Civil Rights Act removed the barrier to
their being hired and the federal law
mandated it I was approximately oh look
go back
I was approximately number 10 on this
rising curve I was hired in 1973 I was
superbly trained I'd done very visible
research as a graduate student at
Harvard had I been a man and applied for
the job
I bet I would have gotten it but I
hadn't thought to apply actually I was
actively recruited by MIT and Harvard
and chose to MIT for my credentials but
I assumed in part because it was the law
you'll notice that after this curve got
up to about 20 women
hence seven or eight percent of the
science faculty it pancaked for 20 years
if you were to plot a graph of the
number of women faculty in engineering
it's almost superimposable on this curve
during this early period
it begins in 1964 with the hiring of
sheila widnall
and then it shoots up about 1970 three
or four to reach ten women faculty
before plateauing for a decade I'll come
back to these plateaus and to the forces
that drove the curves up again but first
a major conclusion from this historical
view why did I tell you all this ancient
history particularly when we have
experts like David to reflect on it but
here's why
I wanted to introduce my topic really by
doing this in retrospect it's very
obvious that not being able to get a job
is a serious barrier to women's
advancement equally clear is that the
early 70s were a turning point that
threw open the doors of universities in
other workplaces to women but what we
did not know then what is not easy to
see and what has taken us nearly 50
years
understand is that on the other side of
that 1964 wall where a series of
obstacles to women's advancement that
were unanticipated and largely invisible
furthermore some of these obstacles were
almost as effective excluding women as
the fact that they couldn't get a job at
all it turns out identifying these
invisible gender-based obstacles and
removing them takes about 30 years when
you realize there wasn't just one of
them but several it's easy to see why
the pipeline leaked and why women's
progress to the top has been so slow so
next I'm going to describe how the key
obstacles were identified and removed
and I'll keep a running list so by the
end of this talk hopefully we'll have a
complete explanation for the leaky
pipeline okay so far we have just one
obvious obstacle before 1964 could not
be hired if no obstacle okay well to
explain how the barriers to women's
advancement were identified you have to
turn now to the experiences of those
pioneers on the front of the waves of
undergraduates and graduate students I
showed you before some of whom went on
to become faculty so the question is
again I don't know if you can say we are
okay what happened to these women who
began to come into MIT as science and
engineering majors then became graduate
students and ultimately moved on to the
faculty but were the experiences of
those women who began to pour into the
system in the early 70s soon after I
arrived at MIT in 1973 I met Mary Rowe
she had been appointed by President
weasoner and then Chancellor Paul Gray
at the request of the few women faculty
who had arrived several years before me
to deal with the issues that were
already affecting female students and
faculty and here is a picture of Mary
Rowe
Mary became a pioneer in women's issues
at MIT and in the United States when we
met she was grappling with an issue I
had never heard of called sexual
harassment she told me that female
students were having a difficult time
dealing with professors who wanted to
date them I didn't understand
immediately the seriousness of this
problem you put men and women together
in the workplace what had they expected
nor did I think that I had ever
experienced sexual harassment as an
undergraduate it took me some yes t
realized that maybe I had for example
isn't that a curious case when I was an
undergraduate at Harvard I was sitting
at my lab desk one day writing up notes
the door of the lab flew open and there
stood a scientist I didn't know but
recognized instantly before I could rise
from my desk and shake his hand he had
sumed across the room stood behind me
put his hands on my breasts and said
what are you working on it was Francis
Crick the co-discoverer of the structure
of DNA did I feel harassed no not at all
I was very embarrassed of course but for
him not for me the challenge was to
figure out how to refocus his attention
on my lab notebook without offending him
what I did not grasp years later was
that a man retreats a student that way
may not be genuinely interested in her
lab notes Marianne made the problem most
of us including those who were affected
had trouble seeing these barriers as
they happen fortunately Mary Roe and the
MIT administration did understand the
implications of this behavior in the
workplace and they said about to change
it you can actually look up the term
sexual harassment in Wikipedia and read
about MIT and Mary's role in this
meanwhile activists lawyers like the
great classroom MacKinnon a lawyer from
Michigan established in court that
sexual harassment constituted illegal
gender discrimination under title seven
and nine of the Civil Rights Act because
it made it impossible for women to be
equal in the workplace today federal law
requires every workplace to post a set
of rules to prevent sexual harassment or
risk being sued MIT recruited professor
J Kaiser to develop these rules and
implement their enforcement from start
to finish it took Mary and J in the MIT
administration about 30 years to all but
eliminate sexual harassment from
classrooms and workplaces and this time
frame it is absolutely typical for most
workplace barriers that women have
encountered 30 years and by the way even
after the problem is solved from 98
percent
you don't repeal the law and throw away
the rule book you have to continue to
enforce the rules indefinitely so you
don't suppose that sexual harassment
could possibly have driven some young
women from the science and engineering
academic pipeline do you I think it's
reasonable to add it to the list okay so
what happened to the women after they
graduated from college and went on to
graduate school in the end
it was dearth of mentoring when I was a
graduate student I had never heard of
formal mentoring programs at Harvard and
I assumed it was because mentoring just
happened as a matter of course when
students looked like the faculty or in
the case of some women like me when the
women were lucky enough to find fabulous
male mentors mine was Jim Watson the
co-discoverer with Francis Crick of a
structure of DNA and have far more hands
off my mentor without Jim support I'd
very much doubt I could have become a
scientist but it turned out that many
women students were not as lucky and
formal mentoring programs had to be
devised and implemented incidentally
this evening you can experience the life
of a female math graduate student at MIT
in the 1980s in a play by Joya de querer
joy was a summa math graduate from
Berkeley who came to graduate school
here leaked out of the pipeline and
became an actress and playwright mass
loss theaters gain do you suppose that
lacking a mentor who encourages you to
become a scientist and helps you to do
so could possibly have anything to do
with women leaving the academic pipeline
I suspect so put it on the list and by
the way although women at the leading
edge of these waves were the first to
encounter these obstacles in significant
numbers they didn't leave them behind as
they advanced to the next stage of their
careers they accumulated them the
barriers were cumulative well if you
were a young woman who was lucky enough
not to be derailed by sexual harassment
and you found a powerful male mentor who
pushed you along were you home free no
during the transition from getting a PhD
to joining the faculty was when young
women were likely to encounter what I
thought when I was young was the only
barrier to women's advancement in
science the family work problem when I
was a student and a postdoc at Harvard I
noticed there were almost no women on
the science faculty and I thought I knew
why it was seemed obvious I could see
that high level science the only type I
was interested in required that you work
70 or more hours a week the postdocs
then were nearly all men many already
were married with wives who stayed home
to care for their children how could you
possibly be the kind of scientist I
aspired to be and be a mother
I found a simple solution to the problem
after obtaining my PhD in doing a
stock I got divorced just to be on the
safe side I decided not to remarry and
not to have children so much for that
problem but know that many of you become
experts in identifying and visible
gender related obstacles to women rising
to the top you will have doubtless
divined that what most of us saw then is
a woman's choice to have children or not
to have children for many of us was not
really much of a choice at all
institutions in which high level science
was done were gendered men and women had
different assign rules the men were
expected to work night and day and
support the family the women to abandon
their jobs and work full-time at home to
support the man at work and that was a
system in the 50s 60s 70s 80s 90s in
fact we still grapple with the residue
of this system today even though it long
ago ceased to reflect or serve the
reality of young people's lives did
women or men really have a choice
certainly not an equal choice it didn't
occur to many of us that this was a
barrier that someone should remove on
our behalf I thought it was a biological
reality that's a woman's choice so
daunting was this particular obstacle
that for decades women in my generation
instinctively knew that it worked they
should never talk about pregnancy or
children for fear that people might not
think they was might think that they
were not serious about science he wanted
to be sure that people knew you are
happy to be a nun of science and in fact
personally I was but the question of
whether having to decide to have
children or not contributed to the leaky
pipeline is really a rhetorical question
we know that it did and I mean no it
still does and studies by Mary Anne
Mason and Mark golden at Berkeley have
confirmed that having children causes
women to leak from the academic pipeline
preferentially so this barrier certainly
belongs on the list well enough is that
it were there any more barriers for
women who wanted to be part of this
fabulous worlds of science and
engineering that was so welcoming who
weren't derailed by sexual harassment
who were lucky enough to find great
mentors who were willing to forego
having children there was one more and
it took many of us 20 years on the
faculty to understand it and I'll tell
this story from a personal point of view
because I was involved with other women
faculty at MIT and identifying and
addressing this particular obstacle so
the final barrier I like to call it I
like to hope
is like many women of my generation I
joined the MIT faculty in 1973 believing
that the Civil Rights Act and
affirmative action laws in the women's
movement had eliminated gender
discrimination I certainly did not
expect to experience it I fled from
feminists I just wanted to be seen as a
scientist but over the next 15 years I
learned I was wrong gender
discrimination still existed I figured
it out at first by watching how other
women were treated what I saw was that
when a man and a woman made scientific
discoveries of equal importance
neither the discovery nor the woman was
was her discovery all that woman was
valued equally to the man and his
discovery sometimes the woman got no
credit at all she could be invisible
these observations as you can imagine
were almost impossible to believe
science is a merit-based occupation so
how could this be true but after many
years of watching through the 70s 80s
and into the 90s how women faculty
scientific contributions were treated
relative to men's I was certain that
women and their science were undervalued
amazingly it took me 20 years to know
was even true of me not just other women
that I believe it's called denial the
realization of this strange truth was
very very demoralizing sometimes I
wanted to quit science alas I couldn't
afford to I came to feel that my life
had been a failure
I had cheerfully given up a lot to join
a profession I've truly loved but I came
to realize I would never be accepted in
it no matter what I discovered worse I
believed I was the only person on earth
aware of this strange truth and you
couldn't tell anybody because who would
believe you
plus they would assume as I always had
that if you complain to bias it must
mean you weren't good enough if you were
really good enough if you discovered the
structure of DNA for example they would
have to give you the Nobel Prize and you
would be accepted as equal right alas as
I finally realized if you're a woman you
could make a Nobel Prize level discovery
and quite possibly not win the Nobel
Prize or even be viewed as having done
critically important work in time it
dawned on me that this strange truth I
had discovered might be the most
important scientific discovery I had
ever made it was so important it is
the Nobel Prize in itself what I did not
know and would not learn for another
decade was that the discovery I had made
so painstakingly over 20 years had
already been made furthermore in 2002 a
Nobel Prize was awarded for a version of
this discovery what I had discovered
unbeknownst to myself was the psychology
of unconscious bias it was psychologists
not biologists who had discovered the
phenomena in the 70s and 80s by a series
of remarkable experiments their research
demonstrated the irrationality of the
human brain to make accurate judgments
and to see truths that contradict our
unconscious biases and beliefs in the
case of gender bias the result of
unconscious bias is to judge identical
accomplishment as less good if we think
it was done by a woman for a related
finding involving irrational decisions
in the 2000 Nobel Prize in Economics
went to the psychologist Kahneman as for
unconscious gender bias which is the
slight overvaluation of work done by a
man slightly undervalued work have done
by a woman
another very surprising thing about it
is the belief that women are less good
than men persist whether the judges are
men or women both undervalue identical
work when it was done by a woman there
are enormous consequences to unconscious
bias in the workplace obviously it can
affect many aspects of the job how the
person has treated their compensation
whether they're hired in the first place
here's a typical example of the effect
of unconscious bias from my era that
relates to teaching when I was a young
professor colleague asked me if I would
like to co-teach an important
undergraduate course with him I agreed
he said he would ask the Chairman for
his approval a few days later my
colleague returned to say the Chairman
had said no because although he thought
I was a very good teacher
he knew that MIT undergraduates would
not be able to believe scientific
information spoken by a woman I knew
instantly the chair was right and I was
extremely grateful to him for sparing me
from a potential disaster but what I
find very odd today is that this
knowledge did not open our eyes to the
serious consequences of the unconscious
undervaluation of women's competence in
so many of their academic duties I
shrugged it off as simply the way of the
world was and I happily continued to
teach the undergraduate lab course that
taught almost exclusively about women
faculty in that era do you think I'm
conscious gender bias the undervaluation
of women's work to contribute to the
leaky pipeline or the failure to hire
women unless novel efforts are made to
see beyond our unconscious tendency to
undervalue their accomplishments I think
that's a no-brainer so I'm putting it
right on the list alas I did not know
about the psychology research meanwhile
I'd come to the end of my line I was
struggling to do research I was very
excited about and despite being a
tenured professor could not get minimal
space and resources I needed and that I
knew were available to my male
colleagues I decided to take my case up
through the MIT administration until I
found somebody who would listen but
happily along the way I must have the
courage to tell a female colleague what
I had learned
I chose Mary Lou ponder a biologist I
admired for her wisdom and her
extraordinary scientific accomplishments
to my utter amazement she had discovered
the same thing I had we looked at each
other and said you don't suppose there
could be others do you without colleague
Lisa Steiner we inventoried the tenured
women faculty in the six departments of
science so we could ask them and we made
the discard lean startling discovery
that in 1994 there were only 1510 in
women 197 tenured men I said this is
impossible it's 30 years after the Civil
Rights Act check the back of the catalog
maybe they list the women separately do
you think we found two women in
engineering with joint appointments
inside science and we added them to the
list the small number made it very easy
to pull them and quickly 16 of the 17
women signed a letter to Bob Birgeneau
then the Dean of science informing him
there was a systemic largely invisible
and almost certainly unconscious bias
against women faculty we asked him to
convene a committee to document the
problem so he could fix it the committee
was formed essentially secretly since
like me these women's scientists did not
want to be seen as feminists the
committee interviewed all the tenured
and most of the untended women faculty
and collected data we found that as
women progressed through their careers
from junior faculty to tenured
professors they were gradually
marginalized excluded from access to
resources and professional activities
rewards and compensations that make MIT
such a superb and envied environment in
which to do science this exclusion
rendered the women's jobs more difficult
and less gratifying the women of course
also noted their tiny number on the
faculty just 8% they suggested that the
negative experience as many of them have
had might even contribute to these small
numbers of women since female students
often told them I don't want to be like
you as one woman remarked who could
blame them either dry the word that came
to summarize the woman's experiences was
marginalization and this is certainly a
major factor in response to this report
then Dean of science Bob Birgeneau
immediately corrected many inequities
and recruited a few women faculty to
administrative roles in science
importantly he also said the answer to
this problem is more women personnel
quickly identified top women's
scientists around the country and he
went to get them and this explains the
second rise in the curve okay here we go
this rise there as the direct result of
Bob Birgeneau response to the report of
the women in science we call that the
Birgeneau bump the original women in
science were absolutely thrilled they
returned to their labs the committee
continued to function under Mollie
Potter's leadership which was a very
important thing but there was more to
come the story of what happened several
years later has been told many times
including in a book premiere
commemorating mi t--'s hundred and
fiftieth anniversary in a chapter by
professor Lotte Bailyn who chaired the
MIT faculty in 1999 Lodi asked us to
write a summary of our committee's
findings for the MIT faculty newsletter
somehow the story right on the front
page at the Boston Globe in the New York
Times the reaction from outside MIT
overwhelmed us we were inundated with
email from women across the country
saying they too had experienced the same
problems of marginalization exclusion
inequity and no one in their institution
would listen to them I believe there are
two reasons the MIT report in 1999 had
such an impact besides the fact that it
clearly articulated an apparently
near-universal work clause place issue
for women the most important was the
Charles Vess the president of MIT had
read the women's report believed it was
true and decided to endorse it publicly
at a time
when most institutions denied and
suppressed similar claims by their women
faculty this to accompany the newsletter
article West Road I've always believed
contemporary gender discrimination
within universities is pot reality and
pop perception
true but I now understand that reality
is by far the greater part of the
balance this was truly a mighty moment
of decision the second repeat reason the
report received so much attention I
believe was because of the scientific
stature of the women who had documented
this kind of invisible discrimination
here is a picture of the 16 tenured
women in science who wrote to Bob
Birgeneau in 1994 and but most of them
are still here at MIT several have moved
on to head other Institute's one is an
Obama appointee these women Hart as
Susan pointed extraordinary scientist
and here is a slide that shows just a
few of the accomplishments of those
original 16 women who said awful this
issue three of them have won the US
National Medal of Science and nearly 70%
of members of the National Academy of
Sciences when someone complains of
discrimination it's often assumed or
said they really aren't good enough but
no one can say that about these women
without looking downright silly
incidentally many of these women were
higher than the 70s as a result of the
Schulz rigs so how did MIT address the
problems of the 1999 report after all
this publicity in a way they were on the
hot seat to find solutions to the
problems the women had discovered the
first thing it did was to replicate the
study in the other schools of MIT and in
particular for this occasion in the
school of engineering professor lonna
Gibson chaired a committee that obtained
very similar results to those in science
the Dean of engineering at the time Tom
Magnanti quickly stepped in to fix
inequities and hire more women by
devising truly innovative recruiting
methods and search procedures but how do
you fix all these issues in the long
term and embed solutions in the policies
and practices and culture of the
institution so the problems just don't
come right back and these are not
trivial problems there were no women
faculty in the academic administration
it was unequal distribution of resources
and rewards family work conflict for
junior faculty was keeping people from
even joining faculties small number of
women faculty the marginalization
undervaluation these are not trivial
problems mi t--'s approach was to
appoint women who had worked on this
issue into the central administration to
work with the powerful administrators
the president the provost and Dean's
with the authority to write new policies
for family leave to track equity for
women faculty to monitor fairness and
hiring and so forth and the next slide
shows the white boxes are the existing
MIT administration and its structure
from president Provost five Dean's the
department heads under that and the
other boxes around them are the
committees and so forth that were set up
under the vest administration to grapple
with this issue in particular I was
appointed to co-chair with the Provost a
committee but as the so I sat on the
Academic Council and that was a
committee of the provost could have
direct input into this issue this slide
shows some of the people that were part
of president vest team at the time to
take on this work wonderful Provost Bob
Brown and Rafael bras was the head head
of the faculty at the time and made most
of these others some of the
accomplishments of three new family
leave policies led by Lori Balin and
engaging the whole community a new
daycare center smack in the middle of
campus so babies wander everywhere now
recruit women to the administration make
sure department heads are inclusive of
women check equity annually but we knew
it would take longer than one
administration to remedy these things
what would happen in the transition from
vest administration to hawk feels
particularly in recruiting since faculty
turns over every 35 years and you have
to track hiring for decades the answer
is the process not only continued it was
expanded and strengthened under Susan
Hockfield leadership so this is team
hawk filled with Barbara Liskov was
appointed to a new position as a
powerful position of associate provost
to work with Raphael rife on these
issues and Dean's Kastner and super
suresh appointed bond hot and sieve to
work with them as associate Dean's and
this has been enormous ly effective and
the next slide shows some of the
accomplishments as say these are
positions that were created educating
department heads about searches
increasingly proactive heads and faculty
and if I could say one thing that to me
has met the most eye
say it was the engagement now of so many
proactive department heads and faculty
and I think the existence of this
symposium the fact that a male
department head of physics proposed it
that MIT selected it is an excel for
reflection of the extraordinary
accomplishments of the Hartfield
administration its commitment to women
and the partnership that was established
under these two administration's of the
women faculty and the administration so
thank you to all involved and how is the
impact of all this well here we see
another jump in the curve that's the
Kastner Steve jump this is the number of
women in science at MIT today now up to
19% and while them the percent of women
in the United States Senate and of
course you do after three such clear
affirmative efforts ask as always has
quality suffered and I hope everybody
knows the answer to that by now
of course not here is today the number
of women in the school of science were
full professors who are members of the
National Academy and I don't mean to
imply for a second that the women are
better than the men not at all these
numbers are too small to be
significantly different all I'm trying
to say is that men and women hired at
MIT are extraordinary all of them so
what about engineering again the work of
Barbara Liskov and Rafael Reif and Dean
Bristow ration and so forth total
faculty has gone from 10 percent to 16
percent since 2002 again maintaining
standards do we even have to ask so
today there are many more women in the
MIT administration versus zero when we
began there are more than twice as many
women faculty as in the mid 90s equity
is reviewed on a continuous basis it's
become routine for women faculty to take
family leave have children get tenure
and have these changes made MIT a more
welcoming environment for women faculty
science and engineers than a dozen years
ago so in honor of this symposium as you
know is decided to find out by
interviewing all the women faculty in
science and engineering in three groups
the women who had participated in these
studies a decade ago more than a decade
ago in the original study women who
received tenure
those studies were done and junior women
faculty at MIT today in science and
engineering and the results are
summarized in that report that was
issued last weekend that you have in
your hands today new report so drum roll
drum roll please
the results I find to be remarkable
really really remarkable change
first of all older women my generation
of perhaps the most impressed because we
have seen such dramatic change but
probably the best news of all of course
is that so many of the women who came
after us are so happy at MIT and feel
very privileged and excited to work here
so here are some representative quotes
from the report if you look at the women
of my generation we just look at who
would have thought it possible in our
lifetime they're very happy about these
amazing changes tended women factly mit
has given me a platform for recognition
this has been a fabulously MIT is not
warm and fuzzy but enabling I love that
junior women faculty this is a place
full of energy and a great place to be
junior so is everything fixed well I
hope I've convinced you that would not
be possible because as you know it takes
30 years to remove one of these barriers
that have hindered women's advancement
and years of monitoring after that and
MIT is only 12 to 15 years into this
effort of correcting the problems
identified in the reports of 99 2002 so
we would expect the efforts would need
to continue for at least 15 years and
indeed problems persist which is why mi
t--'s accomplishment is cause for
celebration but with caveats so what are
the problems that remain that we learned
about from this recent study some are
lesser versions of old problems for
example today many core causes in
science it taught by women hugely
successfully however young women say
they sometimes see that students respect
male faculty more than female faculty
and I'm sure they're right some are new
problems arising from changes in society
for example a to career problem didn't
really exist in my generation
women followed their husbands and
whatever happen happened and some of
problems that actually arise from the
solutions themselves so as my last topic
I'd like to just address one problem
that emerged from the interviews in all
three groups of women faculty indeed
we've heard this from our female
postdocs graduate students and even
undergraduates it's a fascinating
problem which I believe reflects the
problem that underlies much of what I've
been talking about the issue is the
perception that when women advance they
must have done through to some sort of
unfair advantage or a lowering of the
standards when they were higher than
they got tenure when they win prizes and
the negative impact this false
perception can have on women's
confidence I hope you'll agree from my
talk there are two kinds of affirmative
action one was designed decades ago to
increase diversity by temporarily
lowering requirements for certain
schools and jobs that kind of
affirmative action is actually illegal
now furthermore it never existed in
faculty recruitment at MIT except
possibly in the area era when only men
could be hired instead as I showed a
second type of affirmative action was
needed first and the prohibition against
hiring women and then to recruit
exceptional female candidates but why
does it take special different effort to
hire women if they're just as good as
men why doesn't it just happen on its
own because first there are fewer women
in the pipeline so it's more work to
find them second we may overlook women
since we can undervalue them even when
they are as good or better than male
candidates and their letters of
recommendation can also be impacted by
unconscious bias third because for a
variety of reasons women may not apply
unless they are asked why does it bother
women to have people insinuate they were
hired due to affirmative action and does
it matter this is one study we don't
have to do the psychologists again have
already done it ahead of us it turns out
tell a man he was too hired due to
affirmative action and he says so what
I'm the best person for the job tell a
woman the same thing and you can
seriously undermine her confidence
why is there this difference because
psychologists believe both men and women
suffer the unconscious bias that women
really are less good than men so hinting
that women were hired because of
affirmative effort
reinforces this unfounded unconscious
and destructive bias but why would
anyone believe that women who get tenure
at MIT are less good than men
particularly when the data so clearly
show it isn't true where does this
insidious belief come from the answer to
answer a question that difficult you
have to go up the river to Harvard and
ask that brilliant economist University
administrator and my good friend Larry
Summers
here's his hypothesis that women have
less intrinsic aptitude for science and
math and engineering fields was a
stunning public declamation of where
this problem comes from it comes from us
and from the society around us there is
not one shred of credible scientific
evidence that any group of people is
intrinsically a genetically inferior in
any intellectual activity required for
science and engineering least of all
women and not for lack of research to
find it this is not a scientific really
belief really but a bias I think it is
not unreasonable asked by the
promulgating a belief in the genetic
inferiority of women or any group in
schools or workplaces should like sexual
harassment be illegal under title and 7
and title 9 of the Civil Rights Act
since it creates and reinforces an
unequal playing field would this whole
problem disappear if MIT stopped its
conscious institutional efforts to
recruit exceptional women and stop
talking about it
absolutely not bias would still be
present unconsciously influencing
judgments the only defense is to keep
putting it on the table and deal with it
as the new report on women faculty
wisely did
it's the unfounded unconscious bias
itself that needs to change men's and
women's undervaluation of women and
women's undervaluation of themselves is
perhaps the very last barrier to
overcome and we know we have to keep
attacking it because even freshmen women
today ask us how should I deal with male
classmates who tell me I only got into
MIT because of affirmative action these
young women tell us this attitude began
when they were in high school
clearly odd job will not be done until
society sees women's equal academic
achievements as equal the biased view of
women contributes to the leaking pipe
line even for students come to college
especially in the physical sciences and
math how will we know when we've
succeeded when 50% of Congress is women
for starters having seen so much
progress at MIT in just a dozen years I
know no this is going to happen maybe in
my lifetime
in closing I hope you'll agree that we
understand quite well the leaky pipeline
and the under-representation of women of
women at the top of science and
engineering fields and we know - how
scientists and engineers can lead by
example in the solution of what is in
truth a very broad societal issue thank
you very very much Nancy Hopkins we'll
be happy to take questions please come
to the microphones that are placed at
the front of each of the aisle and I
will alternate the questions to her um
that was wonderful and I really admire
you immensely and I really appreciate
this overview and I do think it's still
a lot of problems and one thing that was
missing and I'd speak out of total self
interest on your chart is postdocs and I
have encountered the exact same thing
still at this day in a lab in which I'm
the only woman at MIT and the difference
between me and a faculty members I can't
even find a cohort because I've just got
my lab and I was you know essentially I
feel I have been treated very
differently and held two very bizarre
standards really truly bizarre standards
and I don't I can't say it's because I'm
a woman but I do suspect it does have
something to do with it and I have very
much felt like how can I complain it
just as a sign I'm not good enough thank
you yes therein lies the problem I think
you know as Laurie bailant our social
change is so uneven and so the whole of
it can be advancing but there are
pockets that is if they're 20 30 years
ago and that's one of things that makes
it very painful I find I encounter them
myself
still and when they happen I can get so
angry I think don't these people know
things have moved on no it's a very
uneven process the solution to it has
been I believe to find others in a
network who who can't agree it's being
alone that makes it so talk really
really awful and that was what my
mistake was and not finding other women
and it doesn't have to be exact
we in your field or in your department
but broader but postdocs is something
that the administration is seriously
working on and it might want to comment
on it because this is a very major major
issue they're a group that's kind of
fallen through the cracks there's more
help for undergraduates and graduate
students and faculty now and postdocs
have sort of leg I'll mention a little
bit about the perspectives and
challenges faced by postdocs in my
concluding remarks since particularly
the work family balance is a big issue
for our young postdocs and faculty over
here please I wonder if you have done
any research a multicultural bias I
haven't I did when I was here one of my
research projects was observing
multicultural children in the school
system for a whole year and I was like a
kid every day filming them and one of
the things that I learned was that some
of the problems are you alluded to such
as you know the equality between men and
women really starts out as children and
I have a piece of film that I would love
to show you where this these are second
graders and one Italian boy takes the
credit away seven times with seven
different excuses from a Vietnamese girl
and she never stands up this is an issue
which has been grappled with a lot at
MIT I'm just not the right person to
answer the question I think it's a very
fascinating complicated thing I hope
you'll send me an email and come by I'm
just curious if you could comment on
this the assumption I think that's made
in a lot of these discussions that
especially visa vie work-life balance
the assumption that we're still talking
about women who are in conventional
nuclear heterosexual families
um I say are we I mean you can be in
many kinds of families and have the
children career problem it seems to me
I'm not sure somebody else like to
comment on that I it's a very good point
and maybe we should be more clear about
the diversity of families if that's what
you were referring to you're absolutely
right and perhaps that was not maybe
haven't made that clear enough good
point
hi I just wanted to say thank you my
name is Haiti and I coordinate the
Women's and Gender Studies program here
and I'm very curious do you consider
yourself a feminist now yes apologize to
those feminists who made it possible for
all of us to be here I'm Jennie
McFarland class of 78 and postdoc in the
early 90s and many people here actually
Lottie and Nancy and Millie dresselhaus
participated when we were here we
started a short-lived probably as
postdocs of transient women postdoctoral
Association I don't know if you remember
but you guys were amazing crass so I but
I do want to speak again to the
postdoctoral situation and that
transient nature and the other piece I
think is critical because I did to a
certain extent leave a pipe I've been
teaching for the last 15 years science
at Community College's and that's where
diversity lies both GLBT gender race
national origin language and that
transition I was talking to
undergraduates the University of
Washington that invisible nurse that
they are afraid to say their transfer
students and by and large these are
women and people of color so just
another thing to kind of put on the
table and think about but I welcome the
effort
you make that incredibly vulnerable
transient population postdocs more
public and I think starting
organizations of women in postdocs is
really important but it takes
institutional leadership to keep that
going because they're very busy in
transient group thank you bye thanks to
Provost Raphael rife for his efforts to
assess the status of postdocs there's a
survey that was completed recently about
the postdoctoral experience and a group
of faculty are reviewing that and will
be examining possible recommendations we
can make to improve the quality of life
for postdocs the issues that you raise
and the broader issues of
multiculturalism are incredibly
important on campus there's a lot of
energy devoted to them and perhaps in
the later sessions we'll hear more about
this at MIT and elsewhere how you've
tracked it all the woman from MIT who
have gotten their doctorates here what
they are doing I know I spent seven
years on this campus only three
semesters as of getting a master's and
my girlfriends who got their doctors in
engineering have had tremendous
difficulties that I is a lonely master's
student have never had it just work wise
where their standards were they were so
focused and what they could do and where
they could go where's with the Masters I
felt like could go anywhere and do
anything
and the difference I also spent eight
years at Stanford University is I felt
that the Stanford graduates my friends
there were not having the same struggles
at the MIT woman had it maybe anecdotal
it may be just anecdotal but I was at
Stanford for eight years and the woman
who got their doctorates there seemed to
be faring much better than the woman who
got their doctorates from MIT this is
purely anecdotal I'm comparing ten woman
to ten woman but I'm wondering if we are
tracking where the women who have
received the doctor words where they are
and what they're doing and I'm 45 now so
that's the generation I'm in again I
think this is I remember actually took
this telling
we gotta go find out what happened all
those women who didn't stay around and I
couldn't figure out how to do that study
it seemed impossibly hard but I think
departments now do work very hard to try
to find the answer to this I don't have
them and it's certainly done on a
national scale too and I don't have the
answers I mean I'm interested by what
you say about Stanford one thing we
found is that when people are young they
don't think there's a problem they think
it was solved in some previous
generation different women encountered
at different ages to some extent I have
a feeling the people who figure all this
out early on the other ones ago
those of us who couldn't see what was
happening with the lucky ones really and
we just kept on going assuming there was
no problem so but many young people I
think don't see the problem you know at
the time it's happening and this is part
of what makes the process so slow they
don't think there's a problem and they
think oh that was those old women and
that old generation you know if that
won't happen to me but I so I do agree
it's sort of anecdotal and you really
need to follow through cuz Stanford has
also put a huge effort into addressing
this problem for women in science and
engineering I think with very successful
results also welcome I will be
introducing the speakers for the next
session
I'd first like to thank professor
Hopkins for an inspiring keynote address
I really thought it was terrific
it caused me to think a little bit about
my own view of that trajectory that you
showed so I've had the opportunity to
see that through the eyes of someone
else because my wife is a faculty member
here at MIT in civil environmental
engineering so I've over the last 15 or
20 years gotten to get a healthy dose of
her views about all of this and I think
the most tangible piece of data for me
is that our first daughter was born 12
years ago just had our birthday and at
that time my wife was a year a year and
a half before tenure and there were no
automatic leave policies beyond those
specified by Massachusetts law at the
time
and certainly no automatic extension of
a 10-year clock and our second daughter
was born nine years ago and by that time
we had family leave policies in place
and shortly thereafter automatic
extension of the ten-year clock so it
impresses upon me how much progress has
been made but also how recent a lot of
the progress has been and how much
progress we have still to go so thank
you for just a really terrific keynote
so it's my great honor and pleasure to
introduce our speakers today dr. Shirley
Ann Jackson and dr. Charles vest I'll
start with dr. Jackson and she will make
remarks and then I will introduce dr.
vest and then that will both be here to
answer your questions
so dr. Jackson is president of
Rensselaer Polytechnic Institute she
received her bachelor's and PhD from MIT
in 68 in 1973 she's been a researcher at
Fermilab and CERN
AT&T Bell Labs a faculty member at
Rutgers where she has conducted research
in theoretical physics solid-state and
quantum physics and optical physics she
served as chairman of the US Nuclear
Regulatory Commission from 1995 to 1998
and then president of RPI since 1999
she's the holder of 45 honorary degrees
a member of at least a dozen
professional and honor societies many
many major awards including the in 2008
the American Society mechanical engineer
mechanical engineers Ralph coats row
metal 2007 the Vannevar Bush award from
the National Science Foundation among
many others she was appointed by
President Barack Obama to the
President's Council of Advisors on
science and technology in 2009 she
chairs the New York Stock Exchange
regulation board
serves on the Board of Regents of the
Smithsonian Institution she's a member
of the board of the Council on Foreign
Relations a trustee of the Brookings
Institution and the University vice
chairman of the u.s. Council on
competitiveness to name just a short
list of from amongst a much longer list
of service roles that she has she was
described by Time magazine in 2005 as
perhaps the ultimate role model for
women in science dr. Jackson
thank you thank you doctor waits for
that kind introduction and good morning
it is always a pleasure for me to return
to Cambridge particularly when the event
offers an opportunity for me to interact
directly with MIT students and faculty
especially at a time in its history when
it is being led by a neuroscientist who
happens to be a woman one focused on the
key role of science and technology and
solving national and global challenges
equally pleasurable is the opportunity
to share this podium with my esteemed
mentor and friend dr. Charles vest as an
alumna and a life member in fact of the
MIT corporation and as president of
Rensselaer Polytechnic Institute I
naturally am concerned with the
situation of women in science and
engineering careers particularly careers
in research intensive universities now
the groundbreaking work conducted at MIT
that resulted in the 1999 report a study
on the status of women faculty in
science at MIT was not the first attempt
to understand the special challenges
faced by female faculty but it raised
the profile of such studies and
importantly laid the groundwork for self
scrutiny at many other institutions in
fact since then the National Academies
and I'm not going to say what Chuck will
say but the National Academies have
studied the problem on a national scale
releasing two major publications the
first beyond bias and barriers
fulfilling the potential of women in
academic science and engineering in 2007
and gender differences at critical
transitions in the careers of science
engineering and mathematics faculty in
2010 a quote from the just-released
MIT report in fact one used by
Nancy Hopkins in her fabulous and
important keynote seems to be an
appropriate starting point for my
remarks and that is this is a
celebration with caveats if one looks at
the numbers the progress in
opportunities awards and enabling
mechanisms for women is encouraging
these are satisfying intellectually and
they point to objective accomplishments
reading quotes from the faculty who are
involved it touches the heart and may
provide the most compelling evidence of
change because for most of mi t--'s
history I doubt that any woman would
have said and I quote this has been a
fabulous place to work and yet in spite
of the great progress here I cannot help
but be disappointed by how limited in
many ways the progress has been
nationally after ten years ten years
from the time roughly that MIT riveted
attention on these issues we are still a
long way from gender equity in science
and engineering now in the 1999 MIT
report professor Lotte Bailyn said and I
quote gender discrimination in the 1990s
is so but pervasive and stems largely
from unconscious ways of thinking that
is what she said and it's interesting
what Nancy Hopkins had to say this
morning about it but I would argue that
the challenge of the 1990s is still a
challenge today not knowing not
understanding and not intending does not
get us off the hook
we are still responsible for bias that
puts obstacles in front of talented and
capable people this is both a moral
problem because of course we value
justice but importantly it is a
practical problem because we as a
society are denying ourselves the
insights the ingenuity and the expertise
competent talented people at a time
again when we face immense global
challenges the response to the 1999 MIT
report was immediate with broad press
coverage and a deluge of emails phone
calls and letters MIT woke people up a
direct outcome of the report was seen in
the initiation of investigations across
other schools at MIT in addition the so
called group of nine a group of nine
elite universities in case you don't
know
Berkeley Caltech Harvard MIT Princeton
Stanford Michigan Penn and Yale the
group of nine so-called group of nine
came together and the gender equity
project was created six of these
institutions completed their own studies
that paralleled the MIT approach their
findings on gender equity showed similar
patterns of under-representation and
bias but beyond recognizing the issue of
gender equity and revealing it in
compelling terms MIT also put as you
know the report recommendations into
effect and shared these as best
practices the policies that emerged were
research based not assumption based the
result is that changes have occurred
across much of academia because greater
efforts are made to recruit women women
are invited on to key influential
committees the tenure clock has been
made more flexible at some universities
now so with respect to external success
women have demonstrated that they have
the ability and drive to succeed in
science and engineering and there is no
question that participation by women in
academic science and engineering careers
has grown in recent years what is more
women who apply for faculty positions in
mathematics science and engineering at
major research university
now are hired as often as and sometimes
more than men and of those content
considered for tenure women are
beginning to receive tenure at the same
and in some fields higher rates than men
however the 2010 gender differences
report found that women continue to be
underrepresented among academic faculty
relative to the number who receive
science and engineering degrees and they
are not applying for tenure track jobs
at research intensive universities at
the same rate at which they are earning
doctorates
for example while women received
forty-five percent of the PhDs in
biology awarded by research intensive
universities between 1999 and 2003 they
represented only 26% of applicants to
tenure-track positions at these
universities and women also spent a
significantly longer time as assistant
professors but you know the problem is
not limited to the United States the
need for engineers and scientists is
growing throughout the Western
Hemisphere Germany expects to have a
shortfall of 200,000 engineers by 2017
and Great Britain will need more than
half a million skilled workers but only
18% of tenured professors in 27
countries of the European Union are
women in a March 2010 New York Times
article Katrin been hold observed that
and I quote in the 21st century perhaps
more than ever before there will be a
premium on scientific and technological
knowledge science in effect will be the
last frontier for the women's movement
with humanity poised to tackle pressing
challenges from climate change to
complex illness to the fallout from the
digital revolution
shortages of people with the right skill
sets loom in many countries therein lies
both opportunity and risk for women in
the years to come
the people who master the sciences will
change the world
and most likely command the big
paychecks and that is what she said now
this is a rosy view but how do we get
there what we are learning is that we do
not still understand the problem fully
despite aggressive steps taken by
universities to promote faculty
diversity under representation of women
at all faculty levels persists and
strategies such as targeted advertising
and targeted recruiting have not proven
entirely effective a difficulty has to
do with perhaps bridging to the next
level now interestingly a study by
Cornell University researchers found
that efforts such as gender sensitivity
workshops to prevent discrimination are
not particularly effective because women
do not in fact and this is the Cornell
result face discrimination in hiring
interviewing or grant and manuscript
reviewing at the university level this
study suggested that the major culprit
was timing that women find it extremely
difficult to earn tenure and to raise
children at the same time ironically
research reveals that Parenthood has a
positive effect on men's success in
academic careers while mothers who
sacrifice work for parenting are seen as
neglecting their jobs fathers who make
the same choice are admired and rewarded
writing for The New York Times Stephen
green house noted that based on a
University of california-berkeley study
keeping women in the science pipeline we
or more likely than men as you've heard
any way to leak out of the research
science pipeline before obtaining tenure
at a college or university after
receiving a doctorate married women with
young children in fact a 35% less likely
to enter a tenure-track position in
science than our married men with young
children and PhDs in science according
to the report from the University of
California and this is a quote women who
had children after becoming postdoctoral
scholars were twice as likely as their
male counterparts to shift their career
goals away from being professors with a
research emphasis a 41% shift for women
versus 30% 20% for men and a 2005 report
from Virginia Tech found a
disproportionate share of women make up
voluntary departures from the faculty
because there although women represented
one-fifth of the faculty they accounted
for two-fifths of the the departures at
every step along the way from entering
college as a science or engineering
major to graduating with a technical
degree from entering graduate school to
exiting successfully to getting a
postdoc to succeeding as faculty to
attaining tenure we need to provide
women with bridges to the next level now
as is clear from the studies I mentioned
the unequal burden of family life turns
the gaps in the road into chasms help
with childcare which clearly has been
provided at MIT and the establishment of
parental childbirth leave which has been
provided at Rensselaer coupled with
leaves with support for graduate
students who have children can help but
there is more to be done
studies show that while female faculty
may not feel discriminated against they
do still offer often field isolated and
marginalized in their professional lives
than their male counterparts the gender
differences report found that women who
had a mentor did better than women
without one in fact investigators found
for example that in chemistry female
assistant professors with mentors had a
95 percent probability of securing grant
funding compared to 77 percent for those
without Mentors recognizing the
importance of mentoring the National
Science Foundation provides grants
through a program called Advance which
stands for increasing the participation
and advancement of women in academic
science and engineering careers a
program funded by advanced at Rensselaer
is called ramp up which is our shorthand
for reforming advancement processes
through University Professions wrap-ups
advancement reforms are intended to
benefit the tenure-track faculty at
Rensselaer with special emphasis on
women particularly minority women as
well in NSF funded disciplines our
activities are designed to impact
individual faculty Department schools
and the University as a whole at the
level of the individual ramp-up
initiatives include communication and
networking through colloquy s workshops
and retreats as well as grants through
career campaign awards to help women get
that get over the hump as it were at the
level of the department ramp-up
initiatives include training for
department heads as well as grants for
cultural change initiatives at the level
of the school ramp up initiatives
include the appointment and activities
of faculty coaches who serve as
information resources and participants
in the schools at
processes and at the level of the
university ramp-up initiatives include
intervention on behalf of individual
faculty fairness in promotion and tenure
reviews and a senior pipeline search now
in the end when a woman comes up for
tenure the decision is strictly made on
the basis of what she has accomplished
but the point is to not have a leaky
pipeline along the way and so the
program provides vital help but there is
still unfinished business and so let me
point out a few things that I see on the
horizon that in fact may create a new
challenges or maybe repackage challenges
the first is the shifting context for
measurement to begin for those who are
on the vanguard of gender equity a
subtle problem may in fact emerge
competition because as gender equity
becomes more valued by our culture the
measure may somewhat decline in
influence because the pool of applicants
will have more options now the answer of
course is to increase the pool of
applicants which in no way has been
exhausted however we will need to look
closely to distinguish declines based on
a failure to execute versus changes in
demand
another concern reflected in the report
is that family and gender issues are
still viewed as women's issues now MIT
has embraced gender issues as an
institutional challenge but beyond the
campus of MIT these issues are still
perceived as the province of women now
this is unfortunate for a couple of key
reasons it automatically lowers the
priority of gender equity putting it
into a box often unexamined by others
that is a special interest on the part
of part of the population not all of the
population it excludes as well the
talent the insight the effort and the
wisdom of men and so it makes solutions
to gender equity more vulnerable to
criticism and dismissal because
engagement is an essential element of
social change and the more distant a
directive or direction is from those who
must participate in its implementation
the less chance that it will be well
executed another challenge we may see
will be renewed resistance and new and
creative reactions from those who feel
threatened by gender equity or those who
struggle with the changes it produces
particularly at a time when people are
worried about their economic security
overall interestingly earlier this month
the u.s. Civil Rights Commission decided
to abandon an investigation into whether
colleges are discriminating against
women in admissions but this is not just
a matter of our society perhaps stepping
backwards the world changes and if we
focus only on what we have seen before
we may miss what will matter for the
next generation so let me offer a few
examples first there is one area of
engineering that has achieved equity
essentially do you know what it is well
the number of men and women majoring in
biomedical engineering is close to even
and guess what the salary for biomedical
engineers is flat or going down Veronica
aureola director of the women in science
and engineering program at the
University of Illinois at Chicago has
been quoted as saying engineering fields
where women are less than 20%
pay more so this but some call
pink-collar discrimination is something
to watch out for but where does it come
from the MIT report mentions a concern
that standards drop as women move toward
equity in fields is the value provided
by women being questioned other studies
show that women's pay drops because of
perhaps the double bind of negotiations
if women do not negotiate aggressively
they may lower the price for their
fields expertise if they do negotiate
aggressively especially in academia they
are not considered to be collegial and
may be denied promotion or tenure now
hide negotiate aggressively but another
factor and I'm always one who's always
willing to walk off the cliff is in fact
the uncertain impact of
internationalization and
multiculturalism
here's another factor to consider in
2009 about half of all PhDs in physics
math and computer science went to non-us
students and 55% of engineering
doctorates went to the foreign-born I
think that's a good thing it says we
attract great talent but what impact
does this may this have on our hopes for
gender equity an optimistic person might
suspect that our efforts to make science
and engineering more welcoming in the US
would create a stampede of young women
from other nations but this may not be
the case
a 2006 University of Virginia study of
graduate students in computer science
found essentially no difference in the
percent of women between US and
international students the report
concludes and I quote increasing
international students in u.s. programs
not likely to improve the gender balance
in computing to us accomplish that goal
we will have to attract more women
regardless of their citizenship that is
the quotient so as we seek to import
people of talent and vision from abroad
we also must grapple with traditions and
cultural references that may make it
more difficult for the equal status of
women to be gained and accepted and
attitudes that threaten the as yet
insufficient gains we have seen may not
be limited to just male scientists and
engineers from developing countries
which is what people default to in their
thinking in Sweden women are awarded 44
percent of biomedical PhDs yet account
for 25% of post doctorates and only 7%
of professorial physicians a major study
in 1997 of the peer-review system of the
Swedish Medical Research Council showed
that a woman at that time had to be
two-and-a-half times more productive
than a man to be considered equally
competent now to be sure and to be fair
in some countries women have made great
strides in petition tip in participation
in science and engineering and in
assuming leadership positions of these
fields now let me talk about a new area
social networks have you ever thought
about that and what effect that might
have now as we have seen in the sweeping
changes across the Middle East and North
Africa social networks have had a
significant influence in fact a number
of women have been engaged in helping to
drive change and have participated in
social media which have helped to enable
change but interestingly enough a report
in January that Wikipedia is off
authored by men 85% of the time is quite
interesting especially since for all of
its obvious limitations Wikipedia turns
out is used as a source of information
by 48 percent of American adults and so
an argument is raging about whether the
Encyclopedia that quote anyone can edit
unquote possibly is skewed in favor of
men or is it a choice where women just
opt out of it now we already know that
social networks are becoming integral to
the education of our students and they
may be key and likely will be to how the
next generation will be introduced to
science and engineering and how they
will build relationships and careers and
therefore as we continue to work toward
gender equity we cannot neglect actually
what happens in social networks and as a
university president I'm not clear that
we really understand social network
communities the effect on cognition and
learning social development bias
development and so actually at
Rensselaer we have a research center
focused on social and cognitive networks
that is sponsored by the US Army and it
is interesting in this regard
why well the center is studying the
technology of sudden such networks but
also studying how constituency groups
form in such networks how adversary
groups for how Trust is developed how
truth and rumor are sorted out and what
cultural influences and nuances are at
work but why is gender equity important
and it is important beyond academia if
the United States is to maintain its
scientific and engineering leadership in
the 21st century and to contribute
to helping to solve global challenges it
must have the full creative and
entrepreneurial participation of all of
its people and must continue as well to
tap talent from abroad but as long as
women face barriers that inhibit their
success in research intensive
universities the nation will be deprived
of this vital source of talent whether
drawn domestically or globally our
national and global future and social
stability will be at risk high-profile
events such as this symposium are
critically important to identify and
eliminate these barriers to full
participation of women in science and
technology now I will add that past
experience shows that efforts toward
fairness often provide broad benefits
one obvious advantage to gender equity
is that gender equity provides
experience and models for developing
more equitable systems for people who
are shut out because of race because of
different learning modalities
disabilities and other differences from
the majority that currently holds
leadership positions in science and
engineering on a more basic level new
perspectives and insights pour into
fields when the doors crack open
allowing personal lives to flourish
together with professional lives through
flexible tenure clocks parental
childcare leave recognition that spouses
have careers and initiatives that
encourage work/life balance make the
workplace more humane and it helps to
develop our scientists and engineers as
whole people more engaged with families
and communities
moreover understanding and addressing
cultural differences as we work through
the issues only enhances our ability to
tap the complete talent pool we miss
much by excluding
of town and it is difficult to imagine
our commitment to environmental
stewardship without the awareness
generated long ago by marine biologist
and author Rachel Carson the chief
champion of the Orphan Drug Act was Abby
Meyers whose lobbying began when she
could no longer get an experimental drug
that was helping her son who has
Tourette's syndrome and you've heard
this morning about Barbara McClintock
Barbara McClintock developed her theory
of trans poseable elements so-called
jumping genes in the 1940s she said it
was met with puzzlement even hostility
she stopped publishing her data in 1953
and it was years and years later that
her genius was recognized because she
won the 1983 Nobel Prize in Physiology
or medicine so one wonders what might
have been accomplished for as much as
she did accomplished if her work had
been accepted earlier so the key message
is this through commitment to gender
equity we identify prepare and enable
the people who can uncover new knowledge
and who can meet our national and global
challenges some of the answers are in
the MIT study but I hope that we will
continue to broaden our exploration of
the issues and as we do I hope we will
come to better understand the shifting
landscape of equity measurement the
corrosive effect of defining family and
gender issues as women's issues the new
face of resistance to equity the risks
of pink-collar exploitation the
uncertain impact of internationalization
and multiculturalism on the progress of
women inside
in engineering because women of
multicultural backgrounds are they
invisible women in science and of course
the emerging role of social networks and
their potential impact on women in
science and engineering their
participation in the conversation and in
the endeavor thank you very much I look
forward to your questions and
observations
[Applause]
Wow
terrific just a terrific talk as I noted
I will now introduce our next speaker
and then both dr. Jackson and dr. vest
will stay on stage to entertain
questions so dr. Charles vest is the
president of the National Academy of
Engineering and well-known to almost all
of us here but I will share a little bit
about his history in some of his honors
he got his bachelors at West Virginia
University master's and PhD at
University of Michigan and joined the
faculty there in 1968 where he taught in
the areas of heat transfer
thermodynamics and fluid mechanics and
conducted research on heat transfer and
engineering applications of laser optics
and holography he became dean of
engineering at the University of
Michigan in 1986 and served in that role
for three years and then briefly as
provost and vice president of academic
affairs before joining MIT as president
in 1990 a position he held until 2004
and he's been president of the National
Academy of Engineering since 2007 he's a
member of many different professional
and honor societies a holder of 14
honorary degrees a recipient of many
many different awards including in 2006
the National Medal of Technology like
dr. Jackson he has a very active service
role including Secretary of Commerce's
National Advisory Council on innovation
and entrepreneurship Department of State
Secretary's Advisory Committee on
transformational diplomacy and for
presidents George Bush and Bill Clinton
service on the Committee on Advisors on
science and technology professor
Hopkins shared
the quote from dr. vest I'll share it
again that was in the preface with the
release of the 1999 report he said I've
always believed that contemporary gender
discrimination within universities his
part reality and part perception true
but I now understand that reality is by
far the greater part of the balance
Chuck's candor and his openness set the
highest standards with that report they
led the San Francisco Chronicle among
many others at the time to speculate
that the study and Chuck's willingness
to admit discrimination together would
serve as a catalyst for colleges and
universities throughout the country to
seriously reevaluate treatment of women
faculty members and I believe the report
and Chuck's leadership at the time have
done so please join me in welcoming
Charles vest
thank you very much and it is just just
wonderful to be back here at MIT and
particularly to be here today to
celebrate what we are celebrating and
before I begin I just want to say that I
hope everybody here understands what a
privilege it was to hear Nancy Hopkins
talk this morning this was a tour de
force that few people are privileged to
ever hear on any particular topic
now I worried a lot about what I can
bring to this I can certainly not bring
either the moral authority nor the depth
of analysis that my good friend and
colleague Shirley Jackson just brought
to the topic so I will do what I was
actually asked to do which is bring a
little bit of personal view to what
happened here in the years that we've
heard about today and what I think it
all means but I know I will be playing
at least third fiddle and probably
before this is all over something lower
than that
so we are here to celebrate something
today and I think this something has to
do whether the question are we looking
at a double helix or are we engaged in a
race to the top because if you look at
the percentage of women in our schools
of science and engineering you see this
curve and the good news is of course
those of us at MIT always relish
competition I hope in the right sense of
the word so I hope this blue and orange
dots keep going toward the top because
anything on a topic like this moves
toward the upper right hand corner is at
least going in the right direction so
just a year ago we met a rather amazing
milestone
report came out indicating that the
number of women receiving phd's in US
universities now exceeded that number of
men something that should not be too
surprising given that more than 50% of
university students in the United States
or women but as we know this is an
interesting milestone for those of us in
science and engineering but I don't
think we can relax we just have to be
not quite so fast because as you've
heard in many ways already this morning
this is a journey that must continue and
so the theme of course of this
colloquium was to both look back to 1999
and to stand here in 2011 and look
forward now you have heard today about
the 1999 headline and I'm sure many of
you remember it very well
in the New York Times MIT admits
discrimination against female professors
well I think we are here today to
celebrate the fact that we have made
great advances against what was
delineated in that headline and of
course in the article below it and the
articles that appeared across the nation
in obviously the Boston Globe but then
all the way to the west coast and
particularly the editorial that Ian just
referred to in the San Francisco
Chronicle but just a week ago I picked
up my New York Times not having been
forewarned and saw this title this
headline gains and drawbacks for female
professors at MIT a sense of unfair
advantage and this of course this
headline I think does fairly represent
the content of the wonderful report that
has just been published it says great
things have happened
life has improved but we still have many
more things that we have to deal with
and the report and the article do bring
out the fact that while numbers have
improved while leadership has improved
remarkably in in its inclusion of women
and others the fact is that people are
now particularly young women faculty and
students are continuing to bear what
some of us older folks might think of as
second or third order problems but if
you are the person experiencing them
second or third order statistically
means nothing it's your problem and so
as we have heard we still have things to
do
so let's look back at a little bit of
history that I hope is ancient although
I guess that makes me ancient but still
things we have to think about now I'm
going to give this talk not surprisingly
by the one thing I'm qualified by the
the one criterion I'm qualified for and
that is as a white male who grew up and
experienced his career during the period
of time that or most of the period of
time at least that was outlined in
Nancy's talk this morning and I believe
that most of us who cared about these
issues or at least thought we cared
about them had a very simple assumption
if we simply fill the pipeline at the
undergraduate level with more women and
more underrepresented minority students
then all we have to do is stand back and
watch their careers progress the same
way ours did and pretty soon the problem
will be solved but the reality of course
is somewhat different and this is
exactly the same curve that has already
been shown today but let me just review
it again this is MIT data and it shows
something very clear namely that if you
fill the pipeline and
if you run the percentage of your
undergraduates up to approaching 50% it
did not happen that the number of PhD
students the number of faculty kind of
immediately followed they have they've
gone along sort of parallel tracks but
you know it's got a long long
well time in it and the National
Statistics are even worse and if we look
at the issue which is not the core issue
today but it's one that we must all be
thinking about of other groups
underrepresented in our student body and
especially in our faculties you see that
the situation is even more daunting now
the problem is if this had just been MIT
then people would have said well that's
just MIT but the fact is the curves for
every major school with strong programs
in science and engineering and most
others as well looked pretty much the
same in fact the day the now-famous
headlines came out in the Boston Globe
and then the New York Times I got an
email from one of my colleagues who
shall go unnamed today outside of of MIT
and he said to me only MIT could get
great credit for telling what a lousy
job they've been doing but the point is
it was much deeper than that as we know
now as dr. Jackson said we have to look
at a lot of things and among them we
have to look at our undergraduate
education and now these are national
data this is from a study that just came
out from the National from the
Department of Commerce a couple of weeks
ago having to do very broadly with the
status of women in America and this
simply compares 1998 and 2008 just about
the same time frame that we are focused
on in this symposium and shows the
bachelor degree field
of all women across u.s. colleges and
universities and you will see that yes
there has been a dramatic increase but
there is still a huge difference in the
sheer numbers of women studying in
fields of engineering and fields of
science Biological Sciences doing a
little better than the physical sciences
as you can see but still the gap between
the number of young people coming into
science and into engineering is really
troubling and here are a couple of
curves I put together for this meeting
that I've actually never seen anywhere
else before as simple as they are and it
asked the following question not only
what fraction of our bachelor's degrees
in the United States are in fields of
science and engineering
but how many young men and women come
into these fields intending to major in
science or engineering and how does that
compare with the number who actually
graduate at the bachelor level and first
I'm going to look across Natural
Sciences which includes I believe in in
these data the life sciences the
physical sciences including chemistry
includes mathematics and so forth and
here's what you have for science and the
difference between men and women and
you'll see that 13% or so of the women
freshmen in the United States are
planning to earn a bachelor's degree in
some field of science and just about the
same percentage of men but there is a
very noticeable difference in the number
who actually graduate in these fields
and you see that only 9% of the women
end up end up getting degrees
in science and interestingly more men
actually graduate in the national
science in the Natural Sciences than
intended to measure to begin with I
don't understand the fine structure here
some may be coming over from engineering
who knows but anyway these are still
pretty low numbers now I learned a few
years ago that we tend to collect data
particularly regarding higher education
by saying science and engineering and if
you're an MIT person you think that's
one word science and engineering and I
hope that will always be the case but it
isn't and the statistics are very
different for the two fields here are
the equivalent curves for engineering
across the United States and you will
see that both men and women half of them
do not graduate even though they
intended to and those of you who are
engineering educators here know what
this means it means we are not doing our
jobs and this has tremendous import for
the future workforce in the United
States but what I really want to focus
on here is the number up here women
graduating what this is telling us is
that of all the women who graduate from
US universities 1.6 percent are
engineers this is not a number that can
sustain our society our nation going
into the future we really both we have
our work cut out for us in both science
and engineering but we have some
particular issues in engineering so the
problem that we have most immediately
and that that we're gathered here to
talk about today though is really sort
of at the top of the pipeline the things
that happen at the PhD postdoc faculty
level and I just wanted to offer as I
at the beginning a few personal
observations about some of my journey on
this topic I grew up in a small college
town in West Virginia
my father was a mathematics professor I
actually lived at home went to college
there it was the cheapest way to to get
an education I'm actually proud of the
education I got at West Virginia
University but if we get back a little
bit further
West Virginia is truly a border state I
went to segregated schools this is
ancient history now I went to segregated
schools until I was in middle school and
at that point the schools were racially
integrated a couple of years ahead of
the Supreme Court decision something
we've always been been proud of but
despite that when I looked back I
realized that my first science teacher
was an African American my physics
teacher in high school was a woman when
I went on to university and graduate
school my closest friend all through
graduate school was from India my thesis
advisor was from Turkey by the way as an
undergraduate at West Virginia
University I had a female professor in
engineering mechanics and I had a female
professor two female professors in
mathematics pretty astounding when you
stopped to think of it and one of those
mathematicians by the way and Nancy and
others who really knows the history was
one of Emmy northers PhD students very
famous person so anyway when I looked
backward I realized that this kind of
diversity that I had been exposed to had
a lot to do with maybe preparing me for
things that happened later I had most of
my my teaching career at the University
of Michigan
I was actually there 27 years all
together as a graduate student and
faculty member and administrator and I
will tell you in 1968 and up through the
70s when I was an assistant professor
and beginning to build my career if I
had an african-american student in class
and I taught some pretty big classes
once every two or three years that was
pretty amazing and if I had more than
two or three women in a given class that
was astounding and also you could tell I
could have told you the day I walked
into that class these women will be in
the top five or ten students because the
only women who were doing this were
really committed and and extraordinary
people so when I wake up today for all
the problems that we still face and
recognize that at MIT virtually 50% of
our undergraduates are women
that we have a woman president that the
President of the United States is an
African American things are getting
better now that doesn't mean relax but
they do get better well I want to just
publicly thank Nancy Hopkins and the
Women's Committee today I was so blessed
that their study occurred at the time I
had the honor of serving as president of
MIT because I really believe Nancy
handed me on a pillow an amazing
opportunity to first of all help
accomplish something of national and
global import and secondly to move if
I'm honest with myself from probably
being part of the problem to being at
least a little part of the solution and
I think that's what she and her
colleagues did for all of us and I just
can't say that strongly enough or
without with enough gratitude now the
group of nine as they came to be called
have already been mentioned but with a
bit of seeding of great idea
by Lahti Balin and others we did decide
to invite nine schools with particularly
strong science and engineering programs
to sit down together bringing groups of
men and women from each institution
including the president in most cases
and the provost and the deans engaged
and we had a really quite remarkable day
and we left that with all the presidents
signing a statement that they would
return to their campuses and they would
produce or enable a study similar to
that which was done here at at MIT and I
will tell you it was not easy getting
nine signatures on that piece of paper
not because of any ill will but I have
to tell you the thought in several of
the private universities that they would
have to make available to whatever this
committee turned out to be salary data
almost stopped the whole thing in its
tracks and every story has an unsung
hero here and there and one person I
really want to pay homage to today was
Harold Shapiro who at that time was the
president of Princeton and I will tell
you while I was twisting the right arm
Harold was twisting the left arm he
played a very major role in getting
people to step back and say this is
important we have to do it and I also
should have said a little bit more about
the the impact of the email and so forth
that came after the Hopkins report was
was made public on the web and then
through the the papers and I'm sure I
got only a fraction of what Nancy got
but we were getting like a hundred
emails a day and they all said the same
thing they said this is my story this is
my story first they came from
universities then they started coming
from industry then they came from around
the world and I think for Nancy they're
still coming
well I'm not going to walk all through
this but there are a couple of things I
wanted to say I'm gonna make the case
that numbers are important this was
about numbers
it was about quantitative metrics
measurement I was so excited to see
because I hadn't known before last night
Nancy's tape measure in the MIT Museum
please go see it it deserves to to be
there and when I received the report and
you all have to recognize that virtually
nobody's seen the actual report you've
all seen the public version but in order
to gather the data at the level that
Nancy and her committees they're
actually two gathered they obviously
told people that they would not be
recognized and at certain of these
measurements would not appear public and
so forth but the quantitative nature of
being MIT really struck home but I will
tell you simultaneously it is not all
about numbers and one of the things that
sticks in my mind more than any other
from this period was a day before the
report was released when we were
discussing it there were probably four
or five six women faculty sitting around
the sort of coffee table in the
president's office and we were
discussing next steps and what the
report said and a couple of the women
said to me well the good news is the
junior faculty are happy campers that
was a term she used they're happy
campers they feel well treated their
salaries are strong they're getting the
support they need they're really glad
they're here but before the conversation
moved on one of the more senior women
looked across the table and said I felt
that way when I was their age too and I
have to tell you that hit me in the
solar plexus and just all the sudden
just amplified all the things I'd been
hearing and made me recognize how
complex this is and how different women
and men were in fact experiencing MIT
well I hate to tell you I'm gonna refer
to it again but what I'm gonna tell you
is what you don't know about this which
is that MIT in that period and probably
still today we did a whole lot of our
work by email and I was late in my study
at the president's house one night and
we were discussing that the report was
going the the sort of public summary was
going to be replay released on the web
through the Faculty newsletter the next
day or two and I was asked if I would
write a couple of introductory comments
and I said of course and I just sat down
and wrote out what really came to my
mind and pushed a button and this was it
now what you don't know is that I rather
quickly got an email back from Lottie
Balin saying well Chuck this is nice but
don't you think you ought to say a
little bit more about what we're gonna
do about this so I wrote the second
paragraph which is not here and sent it
Lottie had a lot to do with this an
entire thing but the resonance to this
was just amazing and the second lesson I
learned from this or the second point I
want to make is that I learned if you
simply tell the truth in a simple
declarative sentence people think you've
done something radical and revolutionary
believe me I am not the first person who
ever first male who ever learned this
but if you just tell the truth sometimes
things have a way of resonating and
following well I'm not going to go
through all this because you know what
these numbers represent but this is
basically what happened to the number
of women in serious administrative
positions in the schools of science and
engineering after that these are the
numbers of women on the faculty that you
have already seen today the group of
nine I've mentioned a little bit and I
want to close with a little look at some
of the national data from today we do
have to pay attention to the supply and
you'll hear the same theme again here
science and engineering the production
of women PhDs
has grown up to forty-five percent
across all schools of all quality levels
and so forth but again if you break this
down discipline in terms of discipline
you see a somewhat different picture and
you see that the life sciences have kind
of rocketed and the physical sciences
and engineering are still much much
lower and we do have to understand that
we do have to pay attention to it
particularly given the comment that was
made earlier about the fact that even
today the number of faculty nationally
are not following even in the life
sciences that curve that that runs up
close to 50% similarly women faculty
members all across the United States and
all colleges and universities in the
natural sciences and engineering looks
something like this having grown from
under 5% in 1973 to about 20% a few
years ago I assume it's crossed that
curve now but again if you break things
down life sciences physical sciences and
engineering you find certain ones of us
have even more work to do than others
and finally I want to say that numbers
really do matter this is sort of odd
curve but somehow means something to me
I simply took the ratio in each of
several years of the fraction of PhDs in
the field that were granted to whim
and found the ratio to that of the
number of faculty appointments the
number of junior faculty in these fields
so this has a little noise and the data
the time lags not right and so forth
but what it really does show you is that
there is a direct relationship between
the number of young women or the
percentage of young women earning PhDs
in various fields as that does translate
to some extent into the number of junior
faculty now we were talking a little bit
during the coffee break and I made the
statement that one of the read that one
of the other reasons that numbers matter
are that you really have to achieve a
critical mass before the culture starts
to change and that by the way dominated
all the QA today I believe that thus far
that a lot of these changes are cultural
we first work on what we can measure and
then we have to change the culture and I
believe that happens when you get enough
in this case women into the system and
so I'm going to not finish all my slides
but I want to end with just one little
story here and MIT led the drafting of
an amicus brief for the famous
University of Michigan Supreme Court
case that upheld the Bakke decision that
allows us to consider in this case race
as one of many factors in making
admission decisions and we put together
a an amicus brief with Stanford
University with IBM and DuPont with the
National Academy of Sciences the
National Academy of Engineering and a
group some of you may know called
Nachman the National Council on
advancement of minorities in engineering
and I am told by people who really know
what went on in this case that it was
actually the second most influential
amicus brief the first of course was the
one signed by all the former military
leaders who said this country's got to
go in this direction but anyway because
of my interest I actually sat down and
read the transcript of the hearing
before the Supreme Court now I'd never
done this before and I always had this
image that you have this deep erudite
conversation it sounds like a bunch of
people sitting around drinking beer and
arguing it's really interesting and in
the middle of the hearing the Solicitor
General goes after Michigan's attorney
and he says all right how will you know
when you've gotten there how do you know
is succeed how many minority kids do you
need to have in this case was in law
school
how many minority kids do you have to
have in law class and the guy said I
don't know we have to achieve a critical
mass so well what fraction of it and
like all good attorneys he asked the
same question 25 times in different ways
trying to back Michigan's attorney into
saying we've got a quota system which we
didn't and all he would say was we have
to build a critical mass and all the
sudden Sandra Day O'Connor intervenes
and she says I know what a critical mass
is when I went to Stanford Law School
there were two of us women any question
that was asked we had to give the
woman's perspective when that stops
happening you're at a critical mass and
the Supreme Court decision actually
turned on that statement and so in the
same way I think we need to keep
striving for a critical mass and I have
a feeling that even though it's not a
number or a percentage will kind of know
when we get there thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much again it's just a
super super talk we do have about 15
minutes for questions so I will ask
those who have questions to come to the
mics that are down front
yes thank you both for your excellent
and amazing talks I teach at a primarily
undergraduate school and I see these
students coming in with no background in
math or science or very little
background or very little interest so it
seems to me even looking at the
undergraduate time we've got to attack
it way before that and I wonder if you
could both comment on that well we we
have finite time and I think all of us
recognize that educationally the deepest
problem this country has is its primary
and secondary and perhaps we should even
say before primary and secondary
education for far too many kids it's a
disaster zone and for the life of me you
know I believe that we know what the
problem is I think we know what the
solution is and I say that because there
are so many good examples of high
functioning schools in the public sector
in the United States that all we really
have to do is replicate them and of
course we do have an awful lot of
inequity and cultural problems in our
society but I think we know what to do
but for the life of me I don't know how
we gather the political will and I don't
know surely what you think but I more
and more think that the real issue is
we've got to make everybody in Congress
everybody across the country go sit down
and watch Waiting for Superman and do a
few other things like this to get their
attention because the rest of the world
is not sitting back and waiting and I
will tell you we are facing a huge
competitive challenge but if we just had
a blank sheet of paper today rather than
focusing on the high
and I think we would have headed to that
beginning I think there are three things
that I would say I think we have to
worry about a baseline a baseline of
Education background competency in math
and science for everybody and if we
don't do that then what we end up doing
is sifting through and picking the the
few gems we can find and that's not
going to get us to where we need to be
the second is I agree with Chuck I think
we have to have a national dialogue and
somehow have the conversation with our
leaders the political leaders but I
think the business community and the
higher education community have to weigh
in to this because we are the not an MIT
not of Rensselaer we're not with but in
general we're the recipients of the
products that come out of the k-12
educational system but the third is this
a lot of what happens with public
education in this country happens at the
state and local levels and so whatever
public policies we seek to or whatever
change we seek to bring has to be rooted
in policies that can engage governor's
and others in the states to break the
log jam and that is why I have liked
what the president has done with the
race to the top because it has provided
incentives for school systems for states
to begin to make changes but the
question is one of sustainability in
terms of bringing about these sorts of
changes to seek out the threat of
optimism in there I would point out that
one of the big problems has been we've
been because of this local control and
state control we've been unable to agree
on national standards in science and
math education but the good news is that
the voluntary standards out there have
now actually been signed on by over 40
governors 40 states so a little
like OpenCourseWare if you put things
out there and they're clearly good you
can get more people behind them and the
National Governors Association actually
has embraced this and that's important
thank you thank you both both you have
very interesting different talks I also
used to teach in a small school college
and met many underprepared students and
I'll just give my opinion that if you
want a lot of better prepared math
students and at least this Commonwealth
you will pay your math teachers more
because anybody good in math can walk
out and get a job and they are not gonna
put up with the conditions we have for
I'm not talking about me I'm talking
about the people who taught my kids but
that's by college it's often too late
what I want to ask I'm so grateful mr.
vest that you put distinguish the
engineers from the biologists because
I'm an engineer and when I was in grad
school that was a long time ago the
woman before me who got a PhD was five
years before me so I had no female
cohort I don't know how much that
mattered but it's not that much fun what
was the kiss of death was ending up
getting engaged to a faculty member
because then I was really tainted you
know as keep away from her she has a spy
but what I would and I can say is as dr.
Jackson said that did impact men too
because a friend of mine who was on the
faculty got in really hot water because
he didn't show up to a summer faculty
meeting oh it's been a month of having a
newborn for the first time and he was
called on the carpet for that okay so I
mean this is the generosity they extend
to somebody for family reasons back then
but what what thoughts do you have about
increasing the number of women's
specifically in engineering because I
don't think we have reached personally I
don't think we have reached critical
mass thank you well Shirley's pointing
to me let me say very very quickly this
is a thing we're trying very
hard to work on at the National Academy
of Engineering not surprisingly and the
main thing we have learned is that when
you ask young freshmen in University who
have good math scores and so forth and
so on
why didn't you go into engineering and
especially if you ask young women why
didn't you go into engineering the
answer is always some variant of because
I wanted to go into a field where I
could help people and make the world
better so number one thing is in a
serious way we are trying we're working
with a with the entertainment industry
all kinds of things to simply try to
project the image out there that if
we're going to solve the great human
challenges of food and water and climate
and security and health we're going to
need engineers and we're going to need
engineers who know how to cross
boundaries and work with people outside
the field so first of all I think a part
of this is just simply inspiring and
secondly we run a a website that gets a
lot of traffic but obviously not as much
as I would like call it two of them
actually called engineer engineer girl
and the other one engineer your life
which allows young girls to actually
interact with with a huge cadre of
volunteer Women Engineers to talk about
their profession their career what they
do and so forth so we have to keep
chipping away at it but while I don't
want to put all of it on there all of it
on this I really think if we can get the
media to help us a little bit on the
inspiration piece we can deal with the
rest of it I think the other part is and
Chuck made a point in his talk we kind
of mash things together engineering is
not science and science is not medicine
and and those sorts of confusions have
been out there for a long time but I
think there is an inspirational problem
and an aspirational problem
in terms of people really being
motivated and to understand what
engineers really do and the contribution
they make and and I think the
professional societies aided by the
media of a very important hi actually I
was wondering since um starting at a
young age in the United States we aren't
focused so much on mathematics and
science many girls are striving to grow
up and become actress and actresses
because the United States is such a
media based country while countries such
as China and India who are striving
because of the way they're studying and
their way their education is based how
do you think we can fix that so that the
media is an affecting girl so much as so
they can strive to become actress but
using the media instead so that they can
strive to help the country by becoming
engineers or scientists or
mathematicians and it's a try
well cracking the nut of the media isn't
interesting as an interesting one but
actually part of the reason I talked
about social networks is that social
networks are an alternative pathway
which in many ways are controlled by the
people who are in them that can create
an ability to in kind of a viral way
penetrate the consciousness of young
people in ways that the kind of direct
media the movies and so on cannot and I
think we actually have a task force at
Rensselaer looking at the role of social
media not just in learning and cognition
but in terms of as an influencer medium
because we do have to have some way to
reach young people where they are I
would just like to add two quick points
not to focus too much on the nae but
another thing we're working on is a
project called changing the conversation
in which we've actually done
serious social scientific looks at how
young girls and young boys understand
and respond to engineering and science
and we've come up with a few tag lines
that we're literally trying to get
industry to start building into their
advertising so you get kind of a
drumbeat but I have to tell you surely
will know who I'm talking about but we
the National Academy of Sciences started
something called the the science and
engineer and entertainment exchange and
it meant for the second time in
Hollywood a few months ago and I went
out I was privileged to give kind of the
opening talk to set the context you're
not allowed to wear your tie and you
know all that bit and I'm standing
around beforehand just meeting a few
people I walk up to some guys that I am
Chuck Bass you know who what do you do
and he looked at me said well I'm one of
the Grateful Dead and actually she knows
who I'm talking about and he is really
working at building Science and
Mathematics into what he does so it's
going to happen
next question please
I want to thank you both very much for
your remarks and I this is this is a
personal matter that I'm gonna mention
not a statistical one and I don't know
that I'm addressing a systemic problem
although perhaps I am my attention was
captured by dr. Jackson's mentioning of
a study of women who voluntarily
departed from the faculty at Virginia
Tech I voluntarily departed from a full
professorship at Virginia Tech I was a
full professor of mathematics there and
I voluntarily departed to go pursue
Master of Fine Arts and nonfiction
writing at the University of Iowa I use
myself as an illustration of someone who
felt constrained by disciplinarity
because I have felt myself to be as a
whole person I found my solitary
identity as a mathematician constraining
I'm condensing a huge story into a
little nugget but a moment ago I heard
dr. Jackson also say sciences is not
engineering is not medicine and I would
add is not mathematics and I wonder to
what extent some of what we're
discussing is constrained by perceptions
of disciplinary boundaries in particular
the the prevalence of women in the
biological sciences has been studied a
great deal women in the biologic and
'red graph biological sciences you know
physical sciences engineering and and
the perception was mentioned you know
the perception that I want to help
people and and that's why I'm not going
in engineering but I I wonder whether
this extreme disciplinarity has a
constraining influence on people's sense
of themselves as whole persons
and I'm just wondering what either of
you would have to say about that well I
think many of us recognize that the you
know some of the more most interesting
questions in science some of the most
challenging some of the greatest
challenges in engineering some of the
things that will make the greatest
impact on society are ones that do not
lend themselves to one discipline and
that of necessity you know they're going
to sit at the intersections or come
because of the coalescence of knowledge
and activity from across a broad
spectrum and so I think that's causing
many in many universities to think about
how we educate our students now we don't
give interdisciplinary degrees per se
but we do have our students engaged in
work that crosses disciplinary
boundaries because we want them to see
this is the undergraduates just what
you're talking about and and so I think
you know as we go forward and think
about what pedagogy will really be in
the 21st century we're gonna have to
think about those kinds of things now I
for one don't believe that it is a
mistake to have an education rooted in a
given discipline the real question
becomes you know what one has the
opportunity to do with that education
across a broad front and and and that it
that what happens in the university
should not be inhibiting but as I've met
and talked with faculty here people are
while they nominally come from a given
discipline the work they do crosses many
boundaries and intersects with those in
in others so I think that's where a lot
of excitement lies but Chuck I just
offered two quick points in addition and
one is that I think a lot of this not
enough but a lot of it is generational
and younger folks coming along this is
just more natural for them to cross but
the other thing is there's a professor
at Michigan which has fantastic social
sciences named Scott page and Scott
wrote a book that I don't think got
enough attention but it it really
impacted me maybe three years ago or so
in which he'd actually gone out mostly
in the business world but in a lot of
organizations and answered the following
question do diverse teams solve problems
better than teams that aren't diverse
and interestingly I don't think he
mentions race or women or anything else
that's kind of a broad definition of
diversity which would include
interdisciplinarity and I will tell you
the answer is so clear that if we're
going to find good advances in what we
do and find good solutions to problems
we're gonna have to cross every boundary
we can think of now interestingly he
also finds that it takes longer and it's
harder but the outcome is better thank
you with apologies to those who still
have questions I do want to keep us on
our agenda and just ask that you follow
up with doctors best and Jackson after
we break which I'm about to do in a
moment here I want to thank you both for
just terrific comments very insightful
it was I've written a couple pages of
notes with with ideas here so please all
join me in again thanking doctors
Jackson and best
[Applause]